you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low and man in the wasp
teaming up
great job back there are you gonna say
the same thing to me
good job thank you what was your
favorite part about what I did
really she seems more intense wasn't
just brings and blasters it was skilled
you know I'm an Avenger now I actually
heard what happened to you you open up
the quantum realm that's when his crazy
could be gold still that walks through
walls and stuff solar tech now supposed
to take over the world or whatever if
you want to do something right you make
a list to fight ghosts ghosts that seems
like she'd be part of two to a Oh also
we have to save the world that's major
we can't forget that hey what'd I miss
we were just tiny no I know that I just
want to make sure that these guys do she
just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck
really if you guys we'd be lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm talking ant-man
the wasp deleted scenes there were
plenty of jokes and moments cut from the
movie including more quantum realm
scenes just before I start remember my
Marvel giveaway is running foot all my
subscribers to enter let me know your
top three deleted scenes you wish have
been included in the movie of course
spoilers ahead for ant-man and the wasp
so take care if you haven't seen it yet
it was cool to see the quantum realm
explored a bit further in the ant-man
sequel however by the end of the movie
fans were left with unanswered questions
about this other dimension and that
could be because there are some deleted
and extended quantum realm scenes which
director Peyton reader said will appear
on the blu-ray in fact Reed said we
should pay attention to what Janet Van
Dyne has been wearing while in the
quantum realm because she's privy to
some technology and things which the
blu-ray deleted scene will explain a
little I'm expecting we'll get some
answers as to how Janet survived there
so long or a clear idea of how the
quantum realm works in the MCU now let's
watch this cuts
seen carefully because I think this is
an alternate Ihnen flashback scene with
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne notice that
wast has Janet's red suit in this scene
the final film opens with a flashback
scene to a younger Janet and Hank saying
advise their daughter before leaving on
a mission after suiting up they arrive
at the missile site just as it's being
launched this deleted scene looks like
it's from an earlier extended version of
that flashback and it seems to fit with
reports that the movies opening scene
was completely shot after testing badly
with audiences and early screenings
according to reports it appears the
original opening was set in South
America this cutscene from the trailer
hints that the alternate opening could
have seen Hank and Janet investigating
what was going on before the missile
actually launched through several
deleted moments that would have played
up more the tension between Scott and
hope and a sort of comedic one-upmanship
or battle of the sexes you go low I'll
go high I have wings why would I go low
great job
are you gonna say the same thing to me
good job thank you what was your
favorite part about what I did really
she seems more intense wasn't just
Springs and blasters it was skilled you
know I'm an Avenger now giant man's
appearance in Captain America Civil War
was one of the heroes highlights of the
airport battle so I think many fans were
hoping for something similar in ant-man
and the wasp now don't get me wrong I
enjoy a giant man in this sequel but
seeing him joke around to scare the
ferry boat passengers would have been a
nice added touch to the scene we saw in
the movie Peyton Reed has also said
there will be extra Walton Goggins
deleted scenes on the blu-ray I can see
why Sonny birch had scenes cut from the
final film as his character didn't seem
entirely crucial to the plot however
there are some unanswered questions
about who birch was actually working for
with fans theorizing it could be a
former MCU villains such as a Hydra
agent trying to buy the yellowjacket
tech in the first movie Justin Hammer or
the Roxxon Oil Corporation it'll be
interesting to see if we get any details
on this on the blu-ray and man in the
wasp teaming up
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when his crazy could be ghosts
well that walks through walls and stuff
stole your tech now supposed to take
over the world or whatever we all love
Lois is hilarious storytelling style and
while we did see hank pym meet with
louise in the film the trailer also used
these alternate lines it might be that
similar to the ant-man and the wasp
teaming up line this was a version that
Marvel thought worked better in the
trailers to help explain the rough plot
of the film
Louisa's mentioned of ghosts wanting to
take over the world seems like a bit of
amusing exaggeration but it could mean
something more if we take into
consideration this next deleted moment
it's gotta be unleashed something
powerful this is a curious line from
hope which never appeared in the movie
and I can see why it was cut because it
doesn't make a lot of sense in the
context of the final film it might
suggest Hank and hope already knew about
ghosts when they first pick up Scott and
was somehow responsible for her
predicament which would be a different
kind of backstory for the movies villain
Paul Rudd's comedy background and his
co-writing credit on the sequel means
there are more unused jokes in the
trailers that were maybe chopped because
of runtime and some repetition as well
as a superhero training montage the
following moments were also cut if you
want to do something right you make a
list
we have to team to we're got to fight
ghosts three we're gonna track down
ghosts that seems like she'd be part of
two to a Oh also we have to save the
world that's major we can't forget that
hey what'd I miss
we were just tiny no I know that I just
want to make sure that these guys do she
just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck
really yeah we had a lot of hints about
Cassie's future in the MCU in the sequel
but this is an alternate line that also
suggests Cassie's likely upcoming role
as the Marvel hero stature marbles
already cast an older version of Cassie
for Avengers 4 where I expect we'll see
her reunite with her father Scott for
more on that and my other Ant Man and
Avengers 4 theories tap the card in the
top right or click the link in the video
description
the missing character reported as
appearing on some ant-man and the wasp
promo art at the Consumer Electronics
Show was a robotic style assistant which
was speculated could be a riff on Herbie
from the Fantastic Four comics of course
Marvel doesn't have the cinematic rights
to anything related to the Fantastic
Four yet and the robotic character never
appeared in the movie now what are your
three favorite deleted scenes from the
movie and how much did you enjoy the
sequel let me know what you think and
make sure you're subscribed and hit the
bell to enter my Marvel giveaway by the
way I've got a bonus giveaway for
skyscraper out now you can win this
awesome GoPro Hero six camera click the
gleam link in the video description
below to enter tapleft to check out my
theories about Avengers 4 and Captain
Marvel or tap write for more deleted
scenes like Avengers infinity war
Jurassic world 2 and black panther if
you liked this I really appreciate a
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time you pick a movie lovers